now with Marvel it's like oh this guy
has a an erection or it's like there's
like the powers have gotten shitty like
we keep going Hawkman yeah you know he's
got wings and uh Talons and he can find
a mouse in a field I'm like that's it
yeah don't you want him to find mice
yeah even Iron Man look I get it Iron
Man's a cool guy whatever but he's in an
iron suit who cares I don't get it I
don't get it I don't get it even a
little bit I've never seen one you and I
are just the same uh yeah I just don't
care I see them they are they all
they're all the same it's it's Seinfeld
say it's oatmeal is that what he says
yeah it's all oatmeal yeah he's like you
look at cars they all look like oatmeal
and I'm like oh that's good